so now we start on a unit of about a
half a dozen lectures on probability
theory which most students have been
exposed to to some degree in high school
we'll be taking a more thorough and
theoretical look at the subject in our
six lectures but before we begin let's
give it a little pitch for the
significance of it there's been
extensive debate among the faculty that
probability theory belongs right up
there with physics and chemistry and
math as something that should be a
fundamental requirement for all students
to know it plays an absolutely
fundamental role in the hard sciences in
the social sciences in an engineering
that pervades all those subjects and
it's hard to imagine somebody
legitimately being called fully educated
if they don't understand the basics of
probability theory now historically
probability theory starts off in a
somewhat disreputable way in these 16th
and early 17th centuries or 7th 17th and
early 18th centuries with the analysis
of gambling and but then it goes on to
be the basis for the insurance industry
and underwriting predicting life
expectancy so that you could understand
what kind of premiums to charge and then
it goes on to allow the interpretation
of noisy data with errors in it and the
degree to which it confirms scientific
and social science hypotheses but true
to the historical basis let's begin with
an example from gambling that
illustrates the first idea of
probability and then we're going to be
working up to a methodology for
inventing probability models called the
tree model so let's begin with an
example from poker and I'd like to ask a
question if I deal a hand of 5 cards in
poker what's the probability of getting
exactly two jacks so there are 13 ranks
and there are four kinds of jacks spades
hearts diamonds clubs what's the
probability that among my 5 cards I'm
going to get two of them well that's
really a counting problem because I'm
going to ask first of all how many
possible five-card hands are they we can
think of these as the outcomes of a
random expect
of just picking five cards and there are
50 to choose five five-card hands in a
fifty-two card deck then there are four
choose two ways of picking the suits for
the two jacks that we have and so the
total number of hands that have two
jacks is simply 4 choose 2 times 52 -
for the remaining 48 cards choose the
remaining 3 cards in the five-card hand
and then what we would say is that the
probability of two jacks is basically
the number of hands with two jacks
divided by the total number of hands
turns out to be about 0.04 and under
this interpretation basically what we're
thinking of probability is telling us is
what fraction of the time do I get what
I want what's the fraction of the time
that I quote win if winning consists of
getting a pair of jacks and by symmetry
and the fact that we think of one hand
is as likely to come up as another this
fraction of hands that equal two jacks
it makes sense to think of that as
that's our the probability that we'll
get that hand if we think of all the
hands as being equally likely we yank
one out of a deck the fraction of time
that we would expect to get two jacks is
this number about 0.04 so the general
setup of probability the first idea
based on this illustration with a pair
of jacks is that we abstractly we have
some set of we have some random
experiment that's capable of producing
outcomes these are mathematical black
boxes called outcomes now a certain set
of the outcomes we will think of as an
event that we're interested in whether
or not it happens we could think of it
as the event of getting two jacks or the
event of winning some game then we
defined the probability of an event as
simply the fraction of the outcomes in
the event divided by the total number of
outcomes among all the outcomes what
fraction of outcomes are in the event
and we define that to be the probability
of the event that's the first naive idea
about probability theory and it all
applies to a lot of cases
not always so now let's begin with an
example which illustrates why this first
idea needs to be refined and it doesn't
really give us the kind of theory of
probability that we like so let's turn
to a a game that was really famous in
the nineteen seventies an enormous ly
popular T V game hosted by a man named
Monty Hall the actual name of the TV
show was called let's make a deal but
we'll refer to it as the Monty Hall game
and the way that this let's make a deal
show worked was roughly that there were
three doors this is an actual picture of
the stage set door one door two door
three and by the way this game show
still has a fan base there's a website
for it that you can look at and even 40
years later people are still caught up
in the dynamics of the game so there are
these three doors and the idea is that
behind the doors they're gonna have a
prize behind one of them and some kind
of booby prize often a goat held by a
beautiful woman holding a goat on a
leash just to keep things visually
interesting and that's what you got if
you lost and the contestants were gonna
somehow or other pick a door and hope
that the prize was behind it there's a
picture of the staff there's Monty Hall
and his and the woman who was his
assistant Carol Merrill her job was to
pick doors to open and show them to
contestants to see what was behind them
okay so here are the rules for the Monty
Hall game the actual quiz show had more
flexible rules but but for simplicity
we're going to define a nice a simple
precise and fixed set of rules the rules
are that behind the three Doors two of
the doors are going to have goats and
one of the doors is going to have a
price behind it off in the prize is
something like an automobile something
really desirable so we can assume that
the the the staff on purpose will place
the prize at random behind the three
doors because they don't want anybody to
have a guess that some doors are more
likely than others to have the prize and
they're not allowed to cheat that is
once they decided which door is going to
have the prize it's supposed to stay
there throughout the game they can't
move it in response to the
what which door is it the contestant
spec that would be cheating okay
next the contestant is given opportunity
to pick one of the doors they're all
closed and it's hard to understand how
the contestant would make a choice but
if the contestant was worried about the
the staff trying to outguess him on
where to put the goat and where to put
the prize the contestant should just
pick all the doors with equally liked
with equally likelihood then he can't be
beaten by they're trying to outguess
some he can only be beaten by if they
cheated him by moving the goat after he
picked or moving the prize after he
picked at this point once the contestant
has picked a door let's say he picks
door 2 then Monty instructs Carol to
open a door with a goat behind it so
he's gonna choose an unpick door if the
cut if the contestant has picked door -
that means the door one end or three are
unpicked doors and Monty tells Carol
open either door one or door three
whichever one or perhaps both have a
goat behind them and so Carol is gonna
open one of those doors and show a goat
and everybody knows that they're gonna
see a goat because that's the way the
game works and then at this point when
the contestant has seen that there's a
door that has a goat behind it and
they're sitting on an epic door and
there's another unopened door that
hasn't been picked the contestants job
is to decide whether to stick with the
door that they originally picked or
switch to the other unopened door so if
they picked door 2 and Carol open door 3
they could stick with door 2 or they
could switch to the closed door 1 and
hope that maybe one has the prize behind
it those are the rules of the game now
the game got a lot of prominence in a
magazine column written by a woman named
Marilyn Vos avant the name of the
magazine column is called ask Marilyn
and she advertises herself as having the
highest recorded IQ of all time some IQ
of 200 and so she runs a popular science
and math
a column with various kinds of puzzles
and she took up the analysis of the
Monty Hall statistics and came to a
conclusion and the conclusion cuz the
firestorm of response letters from all
sorts of readers even quite
sophisticated PhD mathematicians who
were arguing with her or with her
conclusion about the way the game worked
in the probability of winning according
to how the contestant behaved the debate
basically came down to these two
positions position one said that
sticking and switching were equally good
it really didn't matter what the
contestant did whether they stuck with
the door that they originally picked or
switched to the unpick door after the
third door had been opened and that
their likelihood of finding the prize
was the same and the other argument very
emphatically said switching is much
better
you should really switch no matter what
and how can we resolve this question
well the general method that we're
proposing for dealing with problems like
this where we're really trying to figure
out what is the proper probability model
is to draw a tree that shows step by
step the progress of the process or
experiment that's going to yield a you
random output and try to assign
probabilities to each of the branches of
the tree as you go and use that as a
guide for how to assign probabilities to
outcomes so let's begin first of all by
finding out what the outcomes are so um
and we're gonna be analyzing the switch
strategy so just for definiteness let's
suppose that the contestant adopts the
strategy that they pick a door Carol
opens a door then shows a goat and
they're gonna switch to the non goat
closed door that they did not originally
pick they're gonna switch to the other
door that they can switch to and we're
gonna ask about what are the outcomes
and consequences of winning or losing if
you adopt that strategy well the tree of
possibilities goes like this the first
step in this process that we've
described is that this
F picks a prize location to a door to
put the prize behind and so there are
three possibilities they could put the
price behind door one door two and door
three okay well let's examine the
possibility that they put the prize
behind door 1 so the next stage is they
pick a door and if they pick uh if the
prize is behind one and they pick a door
again there are three possible doors
that the contestant might pick
contestant has no idea where the prize
is and so the contestant can choose
either door one or door two or door
three at that point the third event in
this random process or experiment is
that Carroll opens a door that has a
goat behind it
so let's examine that passing those
possibilities so one possibility is that
the prize is behind one and the
contestant picks door 1 initially well
that means that Carroll can open either
door two or door three in that
circumstance
because both of them have goats behind
them on the other hand if the prize is
at one and the contestant picks door two
then Carol the two closed doors have one
has the prize won and the other doesn't
have the prize three Carol has to open
door three likewise if the contestant
picks door three when the prize is
behind door 1 Carol has to open door -
so these brant here she's got a two way
branched she can choose to open either
of the two goat doors two or three here
there's only one unopened door with a
goat she's got to open three there -
okay and that describes the outcomes of
the experiment that's the the process in
the experiment and these nodes at the
end these leaves of the tree describe
the final outcomes on this branch now if
you look at the classification of these
outcomes according to winning and losing
well we're looking at the switch
strategy so if the prize was behind one
and the contestant picked door one
initially then their strategy is to
switch and they're gonna switch away
from the prize door
so whichever door Carol opened to reveal
the go two or three the contestant is
going to switch to the other one and
they're gonna lose so both of these
outcomes count as losses for the
contestant on the other hand if the
contestant picked if the prize was
behind door 1 and the contestant picked
door 2 then Carol opens the non prize
door 3 and the contestant switches from
two the only choice they have is to
switch to 1 the price door they win and
this other case is symmetric and that
summarizes the wins and losses in this
branch of the tree now of course the
rest of the tree is symmetric and so we
don't need to talk it through again this
is just simply the case where the prize
is behind to the contestant has the same
choices and Marilyn has the same choices
of which unopened or nod to choose and
likewise if the prize is behind 3 so if
we look at this tree the tree is telling
us that this is an experiment where
which we think of as having 12 outcomes
3 in each of these may afford each of
these major branches
so there are 12 outcomes of this random
experiment of which 6 are losses and six
are wins for the contestant and so we
discover that there's six wins and 6
losses now the way that this game works
if you think about it if the switching
strategy wins that means that the
sticking strategy would have lost
because if switching wins it meant that
you switched to the door that had the
prize and so if you hadn't switched you
must have been at a door that didn't
have the prize and likewise if switching
losses then you must have switched from
the door with the prize to a door that
didn't have the prize with switching and
that means if you'd stuck you would have
won so what we can say is that really
analyzing the switch strategy enables us
to analyze the stick strategy
simultaneously because you win by
sticking if and only if you lose by
switching now this simplification
doesn't hold when there's more than
three doors and that's another exercise
but for now it's telling us that if we
analyze the switch strategy we also
understand this thing
the stick strategy and of course that
means that if you use the stick strategy
then the six wins become losses in the
six losses become wins and again there
are six ways to lose it six ways to win
so the first false conclusion from this
is by reasoning about it as though they
were poker hands and the false
conclusion says look sticking and
switching win with the same number of
outcomes and lose with the same outcome
number of outcomes so it really doesn't
matter whether he is thick or switch
because the probability of winning in
both cases is half the outcome six out
of 12 the probability doesn't matter
there makes no difference whether you
stick or switch and that's wrong and we
will see why so the other false argument
is that we think about what happens
after Karel has opened a door so where
are we the contestant has picked a door
has no idea where the go to the prizes
Karel opens a door and shows the
contestant of goat what's left well
there's two closed doors left one is the
door with the prize and the other is the
door without the prize that has a goat
behind it and there's by symmetry of the
doors that contestant has no idea what's
behind the door that he picked or the
remaining unopened door they're equally
likely to contain the prize and so the
argument is again that whether you stick
or switch between those two doors that
haven't yet been opened it doesn't
really matter and so again the stick
strategy and the switch strategy each
win with the same 50/50 probability and
that's wrong too
what's wrong well let's go back and look
at this tree a little bit more carefully
to understand what's going on
and the first thing to notice about the
tree is that it's not all that the
structure of the tree leading to the
leaves is not the same here's a leaf
that has degree 1 so here's a here's a
leaf that has degree 2
one way to get in and only one way out
and here's a leaf that has degree 3 one
way in and two ways out if we think of
going from the root to the leaf and so
it's not clear that these branches these
leaves should be treated the same way
well let's think about it more carefully
about how are we going to assign
probabilities to the various steps of
the experiment well what we're going to
assume for simplicity is that the staff
chooses a door and random to place the
prize so that means that each of these
branches occurs with probability 1/3 1/3
of the time they put the prize behind
door 1 1/3 behind door 2 and 1/3 behind
door 3
ok let's continue exploring the branch
where they put the prize behind door 1
at that point the contestant is going to
pick a door and they can pick either
door 1 2 or 3 and absent any knowledge
um oh and and also to be sure that they
can't be out guessed by the staff
realizing that they mostly preferred or
won so they so if they're going to
switch they'll put the prize but behind
door 1 to fool the contestant the
contestants protection is pick a door
and random have choose door 1 a third of
the time in door to a third of the time
in door 3 at a third time in a
completely unpredictable way and so the
contestant is going to choose each of
those possible doors as their first
choice with probability 1/3
now what happens next well the next
thing that happens is that Karel opens
the door now this is the case where
Karel has a choice the prize is behind
one and the contestant happened to pick
door 1 that means doors 2 & 3 both have
goats and again for simplicity let's
assume that Carol when she has a choice
she can open either door 2 or door 3
here does them with equal probability so
we're going to assign probability 1/2 to
her opening door to when she has the
choice between 2 or 3 and probability
1/2 that she'll open door 3 and by the
way we saw that those were losing
outcomes for the contestant but here
things are a little different if the
contestant has chose if the prize is
behind door 1 and the contestant has
chosen door 2
has no choice but to open the only other
unchosen door with the goat behind it
namely door three so we could say that
this choice really is probability one
and I got a little bit ahead of myself
here but having filled in the
probabilities on these edges what we
figured out is that the probability of
this topmost branch of losing is we said
well 1/3 of the time you go here and 1/3
of that third you go here and half of
that time you go to this vertex so it's
1/3 of a third of and half of that or a
weight of one 18th and by symmetry this
gets weight one 18th but this way 1/3 of
the time the prize is behind door 1 1/3
of the time the contestant picks door -
and after that Carol is forced to open
door 3 so this branch occurs with
certainty it's with probability 1 which
means that we wind up at this leaf 1/3
of a third of the time for sure and it's
weight is 1/9 and of course by symmetry
the similar weights get assigned to the
winning and the losing so what we've
concluded is that although there are six
wins the weight of the winds is six
ninths because they're worth 1/9 of the
time and that winning will occur 2/3 of
the time likewise there are six losses
but they're each only work occur 1/18 of
the time
and so we lose 1/3 of the time by the
switch strategy the summary then is that
the probability of winning if you switch
is 2/3 and by the remark that you win
with switching if and only if you lose
with sticking it follows that you lose
by sticking 2/3 of the time and so
sticking is really a bad strategy and
switching is the dominant way to go now
we've in class we back up this
theoretical analysis it's very logical
but the question is isn't true and you
can do statistic
experiments and have students picked
doors and coats and prizes and sure
enough it turns out that roughly
two-thirds of the time and closer and
closer to two-thirds the more times you
play the game on the switching strategy
wins two thirds of the time so the
second key idea in probability theory is
that the outcomes may have differing
probabilities they may have differing
weights
unlike the poker hand case when we look
more closely at an experiment an
experiment with different outcomes we
will agree that for various kinds of
reasons of symmetry or logic and so on
that it makes sense to assign different
probability weights to the different
outcomes it's not the case that the
outcomes have a uniform probability that
they're all equally likely so to
summarize um what happens especially you
know this example illustrates the
confusion about a probability theory
that was engendered even some serious
experts but in general intuition is very
important as in any subject but it's
also dangerous in probability theory
particularly from beginners who aren't
experienced about some of these traps
that you can fall into and so our
proposal is that you be very wary of
intuitive arguments they're valuable but
you need another discipline way to check
them and we propose that you stick with
what we call the four part method when
you're trying to devise a probability
model for some random experiment so the
the steps are our first that you try to
identify the outcomes of the random
experiment and this is where the tree
structure comes up if you try to model a
step by step at each stage of the tree
what the possible sub steps are in the
overall process that yields the random
outcome that's where the tree comes in
as we illustrated with Monty Hall the
next thing to do is among the outcomes
identify the ones that you consider to
be of the winning events or the winning
outcomes or the or the outcomes in the
event that you are concerned about
whether or not it happens getting two
jacks uh picking the door with the prize
so you I need to identify the target
event whose probability you're
interested in we could call it the
winning event the probability of winning
the third key step is to try to use the
tree and logic of it to assign
probabilities to the outcomes and the
fourth step then is simply to compute
the probability of the event which you
do in a very straightforward way by
basically adding up the probabilities of
each of the outcomes in the event that
is the four step message now this
monthly whole tree that we came up with
was a very literal and wildly
unnecessarily complicated so let's take
another look at that and a simpler
argument that will lead us to the same
conclusion about how the Monty Hall game
works and we'll do that in the next
video